if you've gone shopping for screws at
home depot or lowe's chances are they
came from henry chen's factory we have
been producing this screw for
about approximately 10 years out of our
china operation
but now these screws are made in taiwan
american demand for goods from the
island whether it's hardware toys or
furniture has grown a lot in recent
years taiwan also controls more than 90
percent of the world's supply of the
most advanced ships which end up in
almost everything from electronics to
cars in 2021 these exports to the us hit
a record 72 billion dollars up about 70
percent since 2017.
this boom in trade between the us and
taiwan comes as both governments have
also strengthened their military
relationship and this closeness has
angered beijing
companies can get caught in the middle
of different governments
uh competing with each other for power
and influence
so we visited this factory to see how
geopolitical tensions have made
operating a business in taiwan trickier
[Music]
so these screws these are
typically used on top of roofing uh
roofing screws
henry chen oversees operations at gc
grand one of the leading taiwanese
manufacturers of construction fasteners
since the late 1970s
back then taiwan was one of the world's
biggest manufacturing hubs alongside
japan and south korea
[Music]
in the 1980s china started opening up
its economy to the world including
taiwan which has been separately
governed since 1949 when the nationalist
party fled the mainland after being
defeated by communist forces
so in hope of reunification beijing
welcomed taiwanese companies to the
mainland helping to cool tensions and
make china the world's factory that it
is today
in china there's lower commodity and
labor cost the cost of china
versus taiwan
for us just purely on the production
level it was about five to ten percent
cheaper
jc grant expanded to china in 2001 and
eventually close to half of its products
were made there but that started to
change at the height of the u.s china
trade war the united states has just
announced tariffs on another 200 billion
dollars
in chinese-made goods with a tariff it
made our china operation so much harder
in 2018 the trump administration imposed
a hefty 25 percent levy on many chinese
products like chen's screws
he said it was one of the first times he
realized how u.s china tensions could
have an immediate financial impact on
the business so the company had to make
a decision stay in china and raise
prices or move somewhere else
taiwan has the benefit of just having
so much know-how that's been kept here
for the past 40 years so
it was it was primarily a taiwan china
decision for us
this is one of the examples of the items
that we shift the production from china
to taiwan
since the terrorists were first
introduced chen's company isn't the only
one that has returned some production
back home
taipei has convinced more than 250
companies to relocate by offering
financial incentives and resources
and this surge in manufacturing capacity
has helped us trade with the island boom
taiwan
shortly after taking office president
biden sent a delegation to meet with the
taiwanese leader who's been actively
seeking a free trade deal similar to
ones the u.s has with canada and mexico
and the relationship isn't just about
commerce but also security for instance
the u.s has sent special forces troops
and marines to taiwan to train soldiers
so are you saying that that the united
states would come to taiwan's defense if
china attacked yes we have a commitment
commitments like this though later
hedged by the white house have been met
with protests from beijing which has
told the u.s to stop interfering
beijing has also sent warnings to taipei
by conducting military drills about 100
miles from its shores while sending spy
planes and bombers near the island
so as taiwan builds stronger ties with
the us it's been moving away from china
and this dynamic could pull each of them
into a conflict
the taiwan issue is
been
a challenge for a long time
scott kennedy is with the bipartisan
foreign policy think tank the center for
strategic and international studies he's
been watching u.s china relations for
over 30 years
in the last several years chinese policy
has grown even more antagonistic there's
been concern about whether or not china
may be preparing to use force and has
given up uh on its goal of peacefully
resolving the political questions with
taiwan while security experts say the
chances of a war are low any missteps by
the u.s china or taiwan could leave
companies that operate on the island or
the mainland in a vulnerable position
the more
assertive china has become it's a
challenge for every company to try and
thread that needle
for jc grant threading the needle means
running factories in china and taiwan
with a wait and see approach we see our
china operation as being very steady for
the time being
but there's probably probably won't be
too many opportunities to make major
investments partially because of the
externalities with the u.s china
relations
the company is also weighing whether to
shift more production to taiwan but that
decision comes with other challenges
given the small island's increasing
focus on manufacturing chips
labor cost is going to be an issue going
forward and that's largely going to be
due to
investment in high-tech sectors here
that could eventually drive up the labor
cost but chen says dealing with that
issue is far more predictable than
figuring out what the world's
superpowers decide to do with taiwan
from our perspective we really would
like to see steady policies no major
policy changes not for china not for the
us and not for taiwan but i mean i think
there's only so much that we can do
about that